bien des femmes de talent qui n'ont pas
la même lumière que les hommes de talant
verrière la caméra la femme lutte pour
se faire une place et ce depuis que le
cinéma existe en france dans les années
70 un seul nom vient en tête n'ont pas
tellement
parce que
pas assez forts pour ça ironie du sort
la toute première réalisatrice du monde
et française cette alice guy hauteur de
l'a fait aux choux en 1896
en dehors de la mise en scène en dehors
des actrices quelle est la place des
femmes dans la profession
elles sont cantonnées à des fonctions
très précises
les femmes sont tout à fait présente sur
un plateau de cinéma sont même à des
postes clés mais je dirais secondaire
argentine pas de script boys
comment vous expliquez ça non parce que
là elles sont attentives là la petite
maman qui est c'est comme les moteurs
sont souvent plus souvent encore des
monteuses mais quant à la caméra
maintenant il a pu commencer à voir
trois femmes je crois que vous n'avez
caméras en france
quarante ans plus tard les femmes
cinéastes ont gagné du terrain
selon une étude du cnc en 2018 elles
étaient 83 avoir réalisé ou co réalisé
un film l'année précédente
c'est encore peu face aux hommes un film
sur cinq seulement est réalisé par une
femme
la rémunération moyenne d'une
réalisatrice est inférieur de 40% à
celle de réalisateur
la solution les quotas en 2010 819
personnalités du 7e art ont signé une
tribune en faveur de la parité dont le
financement des projets soit la moitié
des fonds discourir la dira c'est pas
normal mais à un moment il faut que les
choses
enfin les cookies des actes et des
actions qui soient faites et la loi
change des chantres la parité l'égalité
la diversité c'est le combat du
collectif 50/50 l'a mis en place un
bonus baryté avec le cnc 15% de soutien
financier en plus pour les équipes de
film composé d'au moins 50% de femmes
[Musique]